sources Craig toll is going to tell us
about spots wheat for data management
and workflows in the x-ray light sources
that are probably I would say even more
so than astronomy the largest data
producers in our field
removing the LHC thank you thank you for
inviting me I am Craig toll I work in
their competing research division of the
Lawrence Berkeley National Laboratory
and head up a small group called the
physics and x-ray like Sciences a
computing group we have projects
involved with high energy physics
specifically a few experiments at CERN
and China and in the search facility in
South Dakota we're also working with the
x-ray light sources primarily the
advanced light source at in at Berkeley
Lab but we've also worked with the APS
at Argonne the NSL s2 and Brookhaven and
that'll seal s that you'll hear about
this afternoon from Amadeu so let me
just start by saying a few words about
not light sources about data intensive
computing in general so the archetypal
data intensive experiment that Peter
just mentioned is the Large Hadron
Collider at CERN and they are deep
taking many petabytes of data every
single year about 15 petabytes of data
each year I like showing this old high
because it's very old you'll note that
the the stack of data is and CDs instead
of DVDs or anything else and the
Concorde was still flying at that moment
so this is more just to emphasize not
only the sheer volume of the the data
coming off of the experiments of the LA
sea but also to illustrate the amount of
time that has actually been sunk into
trying to solve these kind of problems
by the scientific community at yes CERN
but there's always somebody larger I
mean the LHC is a Purdue
many petabytes of data a year but that
is dwarfed by things like Facebook and
Google and even the amount of email
that's Bateman being sent around one of
the challenges of course that we face in
the scientific community is that we're
trying to do much more coherent work
with much less manpower and you know
scientific and effort and funding than
these big commercial entities and that
implies that that requires us to really
be innovative and creative in our data
solutions so staying on the LHC
experiment just a little bit more the
Atlas experiment is one that my group
has been working on for quite some time
we're responsible for this software the
infrastructure and framework that is
used for doing the simulation and
analysis this is a big data project but
like a lot of these experiments it also
has other large-scale challenges there
are thousands of people over many many
years that are supposed to be
interacting with this software and the
software itself is many millions of
lines of code for for an experiment like
Atlas and those opposed their own their
own challenges dealing with that but I
am mostly going to focus on the data
challenges today for light sources so
one last slide is just that in addition
to serving the needs of the natla
experiment of the L AC we also have a
lot of work being going on and try to
use these large data producers to do
work in neuromorphic computing and
machine learning and quantum computing
and other things there's a very rich
body of computing science research that
can be done when you have these very
large and rich data sets so switching
gears back to the to the light sources
so the basic energy sciences is the
office of do-e which has facilities at
many different laboratories and mainly
but not only light sources but also
molecular found are
the nano facilities and the neutrino are
the neutron sources at Oakridge and
these are instruments that are being
used by tens of thousands of
experimenters of researchers every year
to explore almost every area of science
and even things like art and culture and
it's an expanding area where they're
trying to get a lot more users
scientists coming through right now I
think of that for the ALS more than a
third of the of the experimenters that
are coming through this the facility are
first-time users which means that
they're not that coming in with a
priority knowledge of how to do the
experiments much less how to do the
computing and to interact with the
software and the data volumes this is a
theme I'm sure we're hearing every in
every talk are exploding rapidly for
light sources the reason is that the
light sources themselves the
accelerators are getting brighter with
higher luminosity the detectors are
getting faster with higher resolution
the beam lines are automating right now
one of the constraining factors that
John alluded to sort of a different but
related reason is that many of the
experiments are done in a way where
samples have to be manually put into a
beam line sealed vacuum sealed and you
know sort of isolated from the from the
experimenters and this can just take
some time but some beam lines are
actually putting in automated robots
which will set change out samples and so
that kind of a human induced injected
the latency is disappearing and
real-time processing in real time even
real-time simulation are emerging is the
critical capabilities that scientists
are looking for when they're they're
going to these these facilities so the
ALS is a synchrotron light source to
this afternoon you'll hear about a free
electron laser light source that's a
linear accelerator but this is a
circular accelerator with the many
interaction points amendment many sort
of a radiation points of various
descriptions and each of these beam
lines of which there are about 40 or so
in the ALS
at the end of it an end station and an
instrument that is targeted at a
particular type of technique
experimental technique and and usually
focuses on a certain sort of category or
group of scientific scientific goals
what this means is that we heard we saw
the 5vs from John this morning it's
always a who you talk to you whether
they're three four or five but the the
variety of the beam lines the data
coming off these beam lines is very
heterogeneous that one of the larger
challenges for trying to address this as
a ensemble problem we have you know real
space data such as tomography and
microscopy where the image that you
actually get off the detector really
looks like the sample you've put into
the beam
we've got inverse reciprocal space data
sets such as scattering or diffraction
where the it's not it's not possible to
directly invert the data back into the
structure of the of the sample itself
but you have to do some calculations
maybe some iterative Monte Carlo
techniques and then we have spectroscopy
which is not usually very data-intensive
but it can be very CPU intensive because
it's it's you know to do the inverse
calculation as is it takes a lot of
compute power and then there are also
some hybrids psychography is a new
technique that's being used a lot of the
light sources and it has both very high
volume but it also has a lot of inverse
capable characteristics that need
computation so sort of the worst of the
best of both worlds I should say so the
typical experimental science workflow at
these beam at these light sources in the
past is that an exist the scientists who
come to the beam line they would conduct
an experiment fix you know the data
would actually be written typically onto
some kind of a hard drive or a thumb
drive or some other hard medium that the
person would take back to their
the two should do some research at their
home institution public of publish a
paper and then the data would
effectively be lost maybe it's not
thrown in the trash but perhaps is
collecting dust on the show that's
something on a concord high stack of cds
so
we envisioned something a little more
modern and automated where the beamline
user would come to they do the
experiment again but instead of you know
doing everything manually data transfer
rating etc there would be a data
pipeline going to some kind of a HPC
Center a data center a compute center
that will could actually do some
analysis proper analysis that basically
in real time do some comparisons maybe
with simulations or some other sort of
way of doing the analysis and then
report back to the user with the some
web-based interface that they could then
immediately use to sort of in real time
inform the next iteration of their of
their data so of their experiment so
this is the vision that we we came up
with and it was and and so spot basic
spot basically corresponds to these
various aerials and the the web
interfaces as well as the work flow that
is that is a executing on the on the HPC
system and this is in and this was a
vision that we started working on and as
soon as we started talking with the
scientists we realized that another
constraint that I mentioned in another
challenge that I mentioned in the in the
previous slide is that the automated
that the real-time the monitoring of
Institute time-resolved experiments for
both real-time QA and for the informing
this next step in the iteration of your
experiments is vitally critical this is
a example of a sort of a ceramic matrix
with fibers in it that's used to -
that's being studied - research
materials for high temperature high
stress materials and things like jet
turbines this is you know inside of a
metal
container here that you cannot see the
only way you can really see whether or
not as you increase the temperature or
change the the pressure on the the
sample whether or not cracks are forming
and and things something interesting has
happened is you have to do some kind of
reconstruction you have to do some kind
of data analysis before you can actually
move on and know whether or not your
experiment is finished or whether
nothing interesting yet it's not
happening so the combination of the high
volumes and the real time component of
it really led us to a sort of a
collaboration between the the computing
Research Division my own research the
advanced light source nurse Kandy s net
as computer facilities in the molecular
foundry which provide to some of the
theoretical and algorithmic components
it's a fairly straightforward and by now
probably fairly familiar
architecture your take data at the
beamline you generate raw data from the
detector and some metadata from either
the that acquisition system or the
beamline or the the users themselves we
initially started suit casing this up
into an HD f5 file at the the beamline
transferring it over across the network
now some of the beam lines that we work
with actually generate hdf5 directly
instead of our needing to wrap it up in
sort of a post that acquisition phase
transfer it across the beam line it hits
nurse facility immediately goes on to
the the file system archive to the tape
system and scraped to the our metadata
database of MongoDB database that holds
provenance and metadata for the for the
experiment and then there's an automated
process that launches a complex or
simple workflow on the on the machines
and automatically executes the sort of a
prior the the standard amount of
analysis that would then be exposed back
to the the user both in the by querying
the database or you know look
at the images directly from the from the
analogy with the real-time cues or do
you reserve cues reserves cute we've
actually done it three ways so and and
we're trying and we're doing it now in a
combination of two ways so when we first
started this so this is sort of an LDR D
project for those who not at the
laboratory that's a laboratory directed
research and development grant which is
largely designed to sort of test out
ideas and develop prototypes in order to
sort of start a seed project for a
longer-term project so when we first
started out we were basically reserving
compute power at the at nursey and so we
had you know some reserved number of
nodes that we could launch our jobs on
then we started using a rabbitmq based
system where in fact we're we're
launching a worker job on node that
worker job is sort of launched by then
the conventional nurse queue which can
actually take a long time you'll see in
a little bit and then third the third
way is the the real-time queues and so
we're sort of we're trying to mix the
the real-time cues in the and the worker
job approach by sort of using the
standard queues for feeding these worker
jobs and then if there's any dynamic you
know resource and that's requirements we
can immediately increase that with the
real-time views the ALS with lots of
targets off of it when its operating
there's a question about this shared
central resources
so when it's operating how many how many
targets are basically shared sharing
that that particle-beam so so you see if
I can find the yeah so this page so well
everybody is sharing the same beam
inside of there the storage ring here
and the the I mean the basically what
your because your I mean this is an
electron beam
inside the storage ring and and what
you're pulling off is x-rays which are
generated by some kind of bremsstrahlung
some kind of X you know so there's these
there's Bend magnets and soup and
there's wigglers and oscillators and
whatnot that actually forced the beam
through you know sort of an acceleration
that emits Browns drawling and so
effectively all of these can be running
at the exact same time right it's a
little bit different than what you'll
you'll hear at the this afternoon I
think from the LCLs where in fact they
they basically are they're only dealing
with one or two you know beam lines at a
time running off their accelerator was
that here we're you know it's very
common for I don't know what the
percentage is ninety percent you know
approaching 100 percent of the beam
lines to be operating at the same time
so you can get the you get the photons
you wants up to a targets yes from the
same the same electron exactly exactly
that's very typical of a synchrotron
x-ray light source silly animations here
okay so I'm gonna just you know change
gears once more a little bit I'm kind of
interspersing the the ATP experiences
and the former kind of a backstory for
some of the work that we've done on the
the light sources so another experiment
that I've been involved in for quite a
few years now as the daya Bay experiment
it's a it's a neutrino oscillation
experiment at the nuclear power plant
outside of Hong Kong about 60 about 55
kilometers northeast of Hong Kong there
are six reactors in this in this
facility and it's one of the most
powerful nuclear power plants in the
world and consequently one of the most
intense sources of neutrinos in the
world which is why we were there and so
this is a 50-50 sort of collaboration
between the US and China is a first
major experiment that really was such a
an even distribution between the or
share between the two countries
it's a anti neutrino it's an inverse
beta decay reaction where you're
detecting you have an anti neutrino
coming from the reactor and interacts in
this detector vessel it generates a
positron which immediately annihilates
because it's antimatter and it also
generates a neutron which takes
sometimes two thermally equilibrating
and release release some light and so
the signal of the prompt electron and
the positron and the and the slower
Neutron at particular energies is the
signal that your you're doing but of
course we don't have the power to the
compute power at the experimental site
to do the analysis so what we do is we
ship all the data from the experiment
either directly to Beijing and then
subsequently daisy-chaining it to nurse
or directly from the site to to nurse
and this is our data flow for it has
been our data flow for the last five and
a half years or so we've been running
pretty steady state for quite a long
time we even have a sort of a manual
date disk transfer because and some
alternative paths because we have a lot
of network interruptions we've had
Network interruptions from earthquakes
from typhoons and even from ships
dragging their anchors across the sub as
she annek network cables but we had this
system which we adopted for the for the
ALS as well called Spade Spade is a data
transfer and orchestration package that
we developed for for experiment called
Ice Cube at the South Pole that where
the telemetry is even worse than it is
from China and you can see that you know
we have features in the data transfer
that are well unknown there's a Friday
calibration every Friday so you get a
little bit of different data transfer
pattern than the steady-state that you
see during a during a typical
experimental day you also have some
network outages and problems with you
know machines etc our system
automatically recovers from that and
this relay and direct mode that I
alluded to earlier you can even see that
the effects of that when you start to
using the direct mode which means you're
transferring data to Beijing and to
at the same time rather than
daisy-chaining it so this data comes to
nurse which is our us data center and it
gets automatically processed by
something we call the keep up production
process and immediately put into a web
data a science data gateway portal for
analysis by the scientists this is you
know sort of the inspiration for the the
spot suite is this automated system that
then has a web in web interface a web
portal interface to the data the physics
for the the science for the dive a
experiment like the LHC experiment is
relatively simple compared to the
something like a light source with a
light source you might be shown you
might be studying grapevines one you
know de to understand how grapevines
respond to drought you might be looking
at the ceramic to sort of understand its
thermo and stress properties you might
be looking at the growth of dendrites
inside of a lithium-ion battery another
day so every day brings you a new
scientific challenge where as daya Bay
is a neutrino oscillation experiment and
that's pretty much regularly yeah every
day every week every month which makes
it a lot easier to deal with but we took
a lot of the same as the same concepts
that we we applied to daya Bay and some
other high energy physics experiment and
are trying to apply it to are applying
it to the light sources so in diabetes
was a real huge success we were we
started running in December of 2011 not
a very jolly xmas for me and some of the
other guys on the Christmas on the
software side because you know really
this the Chinese don't really observe
Christmas that that well so we had to
kind of live with that but we got our
first theta 1-3 result the very first
measurement if they have a non zero
theta one three in the world in in
history within two months of data we are
able even though we're remote and across
an ocean we were able to have full
access to the data and
parody with the Chinese we observed
antineutrinos this signal here within 24
hours of the detector turning on and we
saw the anti neutrino deficit which told
us that we actually had a real
scientific measurement within seven days
and then announcing within just a few
months of starting up was was quite a
success and it's an important
measurement it's one of the 20 or so
fundamental prophets 801 3 is one of the
20 or so fundamental properties in the
standard model that you cannot deduce
theoretically you have to measure
experimentally and so along with things
like the Higgs boson mass it it's a it's
important to measure though because
otherwise the standard model is is just
a bunch of equations with no real
predictive power so just this last month
we succeeded in reprocessing all of the
five years of data we've taken so far
this is about 700,000 files and about
700 terabytes of data we had to adopt
some or develop some new technique
technologies one is very much similar to
what we've been doing with the do I just
describe for the ALS is a RabbitMQ
driven task dispatch method that allows
us to send jobs to any machine that we
actually have access to out there
authorization to run on we had to
containerize our applications so Linux
containers are of course sort of a I
think of them as a thin virtual machine
but it's a it's in essence a a way of
sort of wrapping your own application in
its own environment so it runs and you
know well understood and and sort of you
find in an image that you can run
basically on any machine that would that
any Linux based machine so a nurse
that's the PDS F cluster of the jgi
cluster the Edison machine and the and
the two versions of the core a machine
and then we had the self-contained
partitioning scheme which bundled
together our worker nodes that I
mentioned before
same idea roll back date frozen offline
database which defines all of our
calibrations and conditions and some
slave and master processes and
monitoring to sort of keep the system
going so this is really a big success we
were able to run it in four days on
Edison and Cori what would have taken
ten weeks of running on the high energy
physics cluster at that nurse so this
was you know there was a high
concurrency of jobs for the this I mean
typically we we would be much I mean the
the PDS F ATP cluster is an order of
magnitude smaller than this even if I
had a hundred percent of the the system
and I can't so the number of concurrent
jobs was very high it was limited by the
amount of RAM available on it and we did
notice a big big difference between the
the has role and Edison notes on Cori so
the Cori comes in two flavors and it's a
its older flavors the has well Intel
chips and the and the faster or the
newer is the Knights landing which is a
significantly different architecture but
like I say that the end result the
bottom line is in four days were able to
do ten weeks of the processing which I
think was very very gratifying and for
us and you know really astonished some
of my cars so back to spots week so this
started out as an LD Rd process or
project it's turned into what I call a
pseudo production process largely out of
necessity because the scientists are the
beamlines found it so useful and you
know sort of vital to their their work
that they they really demand that it
kind of keep going and and be up 24/7 at
least as up as much as their as their
beam lines are we started with the
number of technologies from high energy
physics and and the ALS but also and and
with sort of select number of beam lines
the micro tomography beam line
run by doula Parkinsons of sax wax
scattering beamline by that alexander
hexamer is in charge of and the micro
diffraction beam line that number
Tamura is is in charge of we've worked
on multiple facilities although a ALS
our main one and we were partnering with
a number of oscar projects as well so
sudo production running means we're
running 24/7 really twenty four six
because Monday's is usually time off
since it's been turned on up until
yesterday of probably five o'clock when
I did that the query against our
database we had over two hundred four
hundred and twenty data sets stored a
little over 3.4 petabytes of data on HP
SS and disk and we've executed six
million jobs automated on nurse we have
a web portal interface just like we did
for the Verdi Bay that has interfaces
for data monitoring and control job
monitoring job introspection and
inspection data browsing and even high
quality visual remote visual
visualization of data sets and this is
all backed by some of the metadata and
provenance the information as well as
the workflow so just as a sort of an
architectural sort of representation of
what this system is there's the web
portal interface which is on top of
certain presentation templates that we
define for different types of data it's
a it's true that you have this the real
space and the inverse space kind of data
sets but you also have you know a lot of
commonality where in in some sense
they're just images you can treat them a
lot the same way we have the metadata
database and provenance data based in
MongoDB I'll speak a little bit about
that before later and we have this task
queue and workflow management system
which includes the rabbitmq model that I
and
real-time queue model that I mentioned
before data management and resource
matching is basically how we get the
data from the beamline to the to the
facility and then have it manage the
catalog and warehouse and and move
things off onto HP SS generation we have
the API that is based on the nurse web
tool interface it's a restful interface
that a nurse was developed and we've
extended and then under that there's a
lot of sort of api's at the nurse can
theoretically at other compute sites
though in fact we've run a toe LCF where
there's nothing there this sort of
long-term and persistent and underneath
that are the actual algorithms that
people want to execute on their their
data that we can kind of compose into a
relatively sophisticated workflow so
this is a spot architecture and sort of
the nurse architecture involves
networking of course data storage
devices both disk and tape the compute
facilities and then a lot of sort of
ancillary systems and services such as
data transfer nodes and science data
gateways and database servers and
whatnot and we basically use in spot
everything that nurse provides we use
the I can't spell obviously well we use
the the compute resources obviously it
both the the normal and real-time queues
we use both if the global file system
and the HP SS tape storage system we use
the newt api the the rest of our api
that nurse provides along with an api
that we've sort of developed as an
extension to new we're using database
services that that nurse provides and
maintains and that we actually design
and populate and the science data
gateway interfaces which is a
basically the the web portal that
scientists used to get to the data and
you know I think that one of the
important things we learned is I maybe
we knew it ahead of time intuitively
going into this is that you really can't
do this kind of a big integrated you
know comprehensive system other than at
a facility like nurse because you really
need a little bit of everything or a lot
of everything in our case I should know
it's terabytes I can't remember but
there there are collections in there
that are in the many millions of entries
the you know I said I mentioned that
there was something like six plus
million jobs that are are has been
launched and each of those jobs have
sort of a start-stop you know entry in
the collection so you know there's a
dozen million or something it is just
running our one no-work so I don't
mention this anywhere else in the talk
so I'll just take a moment this nurse
has been talking about the spin system
which is I think in inspired by the the
cloud resources that Amazon and Google
and others are sort of are developing
and we will probably want to move our
database and our rabbitmq and most
likely the science data gateway out to
the spin interfaces that's a first step
for moving those not just from you know
a normal a physical nurse server to a
virtual nurse server but also
potentially spinning those out to the
cloud to the Amazon Web Services or
something like that there's a nurse
gives a great place to do it like I say
you can't do this sort of thing without
all these capabilities one problem with
using this is that nurse comes down
times just like the ALS has down time
and those down times aren't necessarily
well they're not at all coordinated so
what that means is that if on Monday the
ALS is down but the
nurses up and then on Thursday nurses
down by the ALS is up you've got two
down days for the you know what I call
the super facility the the combination
of the the two facilities so the
downtime for a super facility is in
essence that you know the union of the
downtime of all the individual
components in that in that super
facility so this is the the kind of
resources that we draw upon at nurse one
of our early successes I mentioned the
automated beam lines earlier in the talk
this is a beam line that this is the
scattering beam line at 733 at the ALS
this was the very first run of the of
their robot they just gotten it in this
robot is going fairly slow because the
safety people of the ALS won't actually
let the people run it at full speed so
therefore fear of safety problems but
that you know but it still eliminates
the the human latency in the in the
system one of our colleagues on the
isandro sub a was actually on a train
from Zurich 2 to Zurich rather while he
was doing his experiment he was able to
on his smartphone just access to spot
website and say whether or not the data
that they were getting was good whether
they needed to go back and redo an
exposure or whatnot and he was really
very effusive in his praise that it was
actually not any different than being at
the beamline at the ALS which is exactly
what we had aim for and which just tells
us the remote experiments are now a
reality at using these kind of systems
at the ALS so let me just take a moment
to describe this term super facility
which actually I coin not Kathy but it's
a it's a the idea here is that it's a
seamless integration of two or more user
facilities so the deal we spend
something like 50 percent of our of its
budget every year on facilities and
those range everything from tokamaks
that John described earlier to
accelerators and high-energy physics or
nuclear science ion sources or you know
cheap facilities etc so the idea it
really is to meld a data producing
facility with a data consuming facility
in a way that is seamless and sort of he
tried the to the the end users the end
scientists so scientists used to come to
the light sources and they would get
light they would get x-ray photons out
of the out of the accelerator they had
to deal with that however they wanted to
they did take their they bring their own
instruments and their own samples and
their you know whatever data analytics
say they had though they wouldn't have
used that term at the time nowadays all
the light sources in essence produce
kind of standardized data for the the
users you know TIFF images for some beam
lines hdf5 images for other beam lines
or hdf5 files for other beam lines other
formats as well has the heterogeneity
that I mentioned in my my one slide but
I think that but and they still have to
deal with these data in a somewhat
bespoke manner in the sense that they
take the data back to their home
institutions they might have the
expertise they might have the computing
power they might have the the postdocs
that are sort of familiar with the about
the technique and the data analysis to
do the work or they might not what we
really want to aim for with a super
facility concept is that they really
that all the all the processing and
analytics that can be done on the fly as
the data are being taken are done so
that in essence the scientists the
researchers are going away from their
experimental experiment not just with
the disk full of images but with real
knowledge about what they're this site
you know that an insight to the science
that they're trying to do so from
photons to data to real knowledge is
that is the
lucien of the the super facility concept
so to test this we did a number of demos
some time ago i'll describe one of them
so this is organic photovoltaics are
sort of an interesting technology they
are the kind of photo will take
materials that could be printed on a
printer a very high speed they can be
printed onto flexible substrates etc and
there's still a little bit early in the
process in the sense that their
efficiency is not as high as as other
types of technologies but they're very
interesting for the for the kind of
future devices that people are wanting
to make with the with with the
photovoltaics one of the problems with
studying these in the laboratory is is
that when we actually when the the
original technique was to use what's
called spin casting it's basically you
have a substrate that's spinning very
fast you drop some liquid photovoltaics
on the on the spinning disk it would
sort of spread out by the centrifugal
force and you know that was that was the
sample that you would study in your
beamline the problem with that is that's
not the way that manufacturing actually
happens the manufacturing happens with
some kind of printing mechanism and it
turned out that the printed
photovoltaics and the spin cast photo
voltaics just exhibited different
characteristics so studying the spin
cast was not really applicable to the
end result of what you were trying to
what you were trying to understand so at
the 7:33 beamline is a sax wax beamlines
is a very typical looking beam line
where you have the the x-ray beam coming
in and hitting a sample and then x-ray
detector here the at the end of the the
end of the instrument of the beam line
and so the idea was that we would do the
data collection transfer the data to
newark in this demo do some on-the-fly
calibration and visualization via the
the web portal then transfer it to
Oakridge Oakridge and tennessee do some
real-time simulation and analysis of the
the data extract the the structural
model of the of the underlying
scientific experiment underlying
scientific sample and then feed back
through the web portal to the to the
scientist so that they could actually go
to the next next how long they're
typically taking data right so it
depends very much on the experiment so
for this particular experiment you'll
see some data in a moment that's only
like 10 minutes or something per sample
so in essence that's the that's dictated
by its it's a bit constrained by the the
capabilities of the beamline data
acquisition system but it's also
dictated by the drying time of the
underlying you know the the solution
that you're trying to study in terms of
the organic photovoltaics the tomography
folks likewise have a spinning rotating
sample and you take many different
projections at you know thousands of
angles at potentially more and those are
again limited a little bit by the data
acquisition system and the capabilities
that but are largely sort of constrained
by the amount of energy you want to dump
into the system and that the rotating
speed of the of the turntable so again
for them 10 minutes 15 minutes for a
single sample is common now there are
other types of but then but then you
might actually have an experiment which
is you know several exposures of a
particular sample then you change the
condition of the sample you know put
some stress on that put some flow
through it whatever and then do the same
thing over and over again these in
Scituate spearmint swear you're actually
looking for a
evolution of the system to some known or
unknown state or you know development of
a future or or yeah that you're trying
to study basically so John mentioned
that the real-time the near real-time
idea of the diffusion analysis we have
the same near-real-time sort of concept
where that real-time is kind of you know
minute that near real-time is minutes
between one exposure one experiment in
the next but when you ask the scientists
how fast you want your results out they
say seconds we haven't got there yet by
any stress but give them you know you
change their numbers from you know
months or weeks to you know days and
hours and then they want minutes and
next seconds so it's the nature of
success so in any case this experiment
this demo was was done like I said they
taking data at the ALS transferring it
to nurse transferring some subset of it
to the overage for the the GPU cluster
doing some calculations transferring
information back to to nurse and
displaying it via the the web portal
there's a lot of things that we had to
do to sort of make that possible and the
experiment like I said wasn't spin
casting but we actually used a slot dye
printer to print it on to print the ovie
the the solution on to a silicon strip
the x-ray data would produce I have to
do a little trickery to get this movie
to work there it goes and you'd get this
as a time resolved or the time evolution
of features in the scattering and you'll
see that you'll see a couple things here
one is that there's only a certain level
of period of time that the information
is actually changed that the pattern is
changing and it's mostly constrained to
a single a single place of you know
spatial sort of region of interest in
the in the scattered pattern and this
was transferred in the simulation the
sort of a reverse Monte Carlo approach
doing data analysis was executed to get
results on the Oakridge machine turned
out that this is much much slower than
it needed to be for the for the
real-time system but it was a good
demonstration of the of the overall
principles and one of the things that
was slow is that if you transfer the
entire data set over and then do the
analysis on the entire data set it's not
so much the data transfer that's that's
the bottleneck but rather the the the
you just end up doing a much much more
intense reverse Monte Carlo simulation
analysis than than if you narrow it in
on the region of interest trust where
things are changing and you know when
things are changing so in this de Deus
project that I'm on we've been trying to
look at that and the original idea was
over time you know things are stable
until something changes and they're
stable again you saw that in the in the
diagram the the animation I just showed
of a real of real data and there's only
so much of the scattering angle which is
actually of interest in this scattering
angle you can turn this scattering
pattern you can actually see the the
shape of that slot died printer here is
a shadow of the x-rays but the real work
the real information is the real the
data of interest is down here in the in
the corner of the the very at the very
right in the in line with a beam so the
idea would furthest deduce was to sort
of try and find that something some way
of measuring this period this transits
this phase transition period and
constrain it down to a region of
interest both in time and in space and
indeed we've done some work on that and
done some some processing which is very
simple and very fast we can do it at the
beamline it's as you see it looks almost
exactly like the the fake curve that I
imagined it would and we are in the
process of trying to integrate that with
the the front front end of the the data
pipeline so that we can can
strain or prioritize at least only the
data which is of interest instead of the
entire data set that will actually
reduce both the I mean if we're willing
to throw away data which we aren't in
the first phase it'll reduce data our
data network bandwidth required but it
can also we it would also reduce the
amount of CPU required to do the
analysis so
I use the word the term workflows a lot
and this is what we sort of envisioned
one of the ALS workflows being it's you
know it's a it's a directed acyclic
graph of nodes that are correspond to
processing components and connections
between them some of these are
parallelized some of these are
sequential there there's a you know it's
a there's a lot of underlying complexity
to this to deal with the the parallelism
in particular but one of the things we
learned early on is the not every single
workflow is it needs to be run for the
earliest results so initially we didn't
have this last this bottom line which is
what we call the fast tomoow pie line we
were in essence taking all the data
processing it through tomographic
reconstruction generating images from
that and then displaying those in the
webpages that was actually fairly slow
slower than we needed it to be and so we
take this fast to apply which takes a
sampling of the of the data and does a
lower fidelity but much faster
reconstruction and that way we can get
the results out to the users in much
faster time indeed shown here there's a
there's a kind of plot that I generate a
lot which is stages a lot of the
processing versus time the different
nodes here are the different histogram
lengths here are just the indicative of
how long a particular stage executes
oranges queue wait time and green is
execution time so it used to be that in
order for scientists to really see the
the the first indication of
reconstructed data they had to wait
until this stage which its way to
resolution low resolution to to read
what that number is but it's in the many
tens of minutes and and by going to the
faster map I we reduced it to two
minutes or so once the data actually
starts processing this is you know
a big improvement it's not the seconds
that we're being requested but it's even
a little uglier than this
I just wanted to show a couple of things
so this is you know sort of six
different iterations of the workflow for
this one beam line and what you can see
is that it started out being relatively
simple and slow
we made it more complex and parallelized
it and then had to deal with the nurse
cue wait times we were talking about the
real time versus the rabbitmq approach
to solving those problems and then
finally you know got beat a lot of those
demons and problems and then and and
ended up injecting the faster mo PI down
here at the bottom but as you can see
one of the aspects of this is that the
analysis actually although it's stable
for a particular period of time it
evolves over the history of the the
beamline the other thing that evolves is
sort of just the end to end system you
know we have new hardware coming in we
have new beat Network coming in we you
know have changes in software so in the
XOR project we've been doing some change
point detection and anomaly detection of
the of the data transfers between the
ALS and nurse whether we can understand
when things are are behaving as they
should be and when we might actually
have to address a problem it is a you
know in the super facility concept it is
sort of the responsibility of the
infrastructure software and
infrastructure hardware computing
hardware to really be up as as often as
the for the same period of time as the
accelerator is so being able to detect
these problems and respond to them in
real time is one of the critical aspects
of making this concept work you'll see
that for this the big change points are
the the horizontal blue lines the sort
of model that's a data driven model
statistical model of the of the data
transfer is this red line and and so
measuring the the real data transfer
versus the predicted data transfers a
way we actually detect anomalies and
indeed
here's an anomaly that corresponds to a
nurse Network performance that the drop
that we detect in their log files and we
see that in our data even if you don't
have the access to the to the email of
problems outages at nurse but it's not
just network transfers that are are need
to be monitored in essence we we had an
outage these are both in September this
is September 7 2017 and this is 2015 I
think but in September last year we had
an outage where everything just kind of
ground to a spot that stopped but we
couldn't figure it out because the data
transfer looked fine this compute on
both ends look fine turns out that the
RAID controller for the NFS file server
that was down that the beam line had
been miss configured in a reboot or
something like that and so data transfer
data duplication times from one machine
to another machine on NFS basically went
from tens of seconds to many hundreds
and sometimes thousands of seconds so
diagnosing this was this problem was
effectively a manual process and we want
to get to the point where these sort of
anomalies and and patterns are sort of
flagged for us
even without presupposing that we know
about the the what parts of the the end
and pipeline might misbehave so I'm
running out of time we're going to
integrate with the Elks or stack and
help services that nurse so that we can
actually get both information at nurse
and information from our applications
and and data pipeline that that will
allow us to sort of do that even machine
learning on the the data that are stored
in the elastic so
database if this is a big system that
takes already many billions of
measurements per day at nurse weird that
I've got just a few slides and then
maybe I'd skip over them very fast but
it's not just a data the ALS and all
these data processing pipelines are
really big CPU needs as well and when
you have something like a real-time
access and start talking about the super
facility concept you very quickly start
having scientists imagine new ways of
using the facility the the one that the
numerated here is often the scientists
will come in they want to have simulated
there's experiment beforehand you know
they want to analyze that after hand but
but even during the experiment they
would like to have some you know what
they call a digital twin which is a
simulation that's running concurrently
with the data taking so you can actually
you know understand whether or not the
experiment is behaving as you expect it
to if not respond to it and and do some
do some either analysis or or tweaking
of the experimental setup so in closing
I'll just say that you know the super
facility concept is still that it's a
concept it's gaining a lot of traction
at de headquarters I think in large
measure because this combination of data
source facility and computes facility is
really the way to go because the when
the ALS and other light sources began it
was really individual desktop machines
that were doing it doing the analysis
the the data flow and complexity of the
data volumes and rates and the
complexity of the calculation have made
it you know so have out passed that
technology and they really need the
high-performance computing capabilities
that something like nurse can bring that
off stop and after places
[Applause]
okay I actually want to a me with an
idea good first so super facility always
been thought of as many places working
together to handle the issues set
enriches my downtime is fine so long as
it's your downtime exactly what about
the idea of proposing to do a that are
gone of courage and each devote a rack
to a mini super facility to test some of
these ideas what would be the minimum
amount to make it useful for say the
workflows that you're doing so so this
is a good idea and I would I would throw
in there even something like cloud
resources as well yeah because right and
in the past the the constraint against
running on nurse and on Oak Ridge and on
Argonne machines was the heterogeneity
of the underlying architectures
containers help to sort of alleviate
that to some degree right but it's still
I think especially for the Argonne
blue-jean architecture I don't honestly
know if you can run an image on that or
not the the Oakridge gpu-based machine
you can run images on that and you could
pop you could even utilize something
like the Cades resource at Oakridge i
think this is really the right way to
think about it though is that in you
know nurse Cassie's down times mostly
planned but also sometimes unplanned and
it they they don't make any kind of
explicit effort to coordinate with the
ALS or with LCLs or some of the other
data source facilities and and I don't
think it's practical to expect that
because the that would then imply that
the ALS
LCLs coordinate are down times or you
know maybe even with daya Bay or other
facilities and and the common tourist
gets too high they come in at torts on
the compute side don't get so high if
you've got three facilities where you
can say oh oh we're gonna you know we're
gonna go down you know the last week in
February and make sure that the other
two facilities have some capability so I
think it's a is a good way to go I have
we have talked about using cloud
resources for failover a very small
amounts of computing now the entire
workflow of maybe just the the prompt
reconstruction that is describing of
Lahore if we could send off a small
subset of data to the Amazon Web
Services and run the fast Toma pie on
those you get the fast turnaround
reconstruction results but you just have
to wait for the facility to come back
for results or full access of the user
to the so yeah I coined the phrase
initially and and it sort of been it's
been sort of you know adopted by many
people sometimes meaning different
things right so am I in my mind so that
the ALS nurse yes that is sort of an
archetypal sort of put a super facility
where you have the data producer the
data consumer and the data transfer now
yes net ALS and nurse have existed for
decades right that doesn't mean it's a
super facility what's really required to
to make those in you know those disjoint
discrete DOA facilities into super
facility as they is the the inference
sure the software infrastructure that
actually you know ties these things all
together so we have many of the
components of it we are still struggling
with things like federated identities
between the different facilities some
way of you know feed you know some
feedback loops so that you can actually
understand you know other than somebody
typing in Monday February you know 26
for the downtime for a nurse you know
some way it's sort of in you know do
that and automate away we have a lot of
work as you know on the X off-site for
instrumentation of applications and the
hardware to sort of do monitoring and
and an understanding of the ant and
workflow and and whether it's behaving
properly or whether it's failing there's
a lot of I think common ideas that many
people at these you know in high energy
physics experiments and light sources
and genome you know sequencers and
whatnot are utilizing I put up my spot
architecture you know that's a bit of an
implementation specific architecture I
think that it's some kind of more
abstract reference architecture that is
the super facility is really what you
know do we researchers need to kind of
come to some agreement on there's
there's other reference architectures
for things like hierarchical storage
systems and whatnot that if we could you
know adopt something like that then
people would are gone and that Berkeley
could actually talk about which pieces
are corresponding to which other pieces
right now it's a the boundaries are not
the same and so it's often the case that
is impossible understand whether you
want to evaluate something that someone
else is utilizing or whether it even you
know matches into your into your your
system that wasn't a very precise answer
the facilities like yes providing Amazon
Web Services like a PA I used to access
and control yeah right so one of the
things that nurse did that I thought was
really good was this newt newt api which
is his restful interface to the
underlying resources and that was good
because that what they did that early
right I mean supercomputing facilities
have historically operated on on the the
model of you a user logging into the
Machine through some gateway you know
obviously into interactive notes and
then running on it you know so many jobs
into the batch queue and then going away
and coming back later and to look at the
results for these automated systems
these distributed automated you know
workflow driven systems that doesn't
work right I mean you really need to you
really need something that can you know
interact with the communicate with your
software infrastructure and run on a
24/7 basis so this brings to mind
another one in addition to things like
federated identity and other cyber
security related issue which is nurse
cos considering multi-factor
authentication as a to enhance their
their cybersecurity stance enhancer
degrade I'm not sure which is the right
verb but that also is something that
have has implications for a non human
you know sort of actor
interacting with the system right I mean
if if every single data file I sent
across needed a multi-factor
authentication the system would grind to
a stop stop we've talked a lot with the
nurse people when they are you know both
very aware of and accommodating of this
kind of this kind of a use case so I I'm
certain they're what we will end up with
is gonna suit our needs fingers
without the st. Craig again thank you
very much sir
[Music]